[Música]
y venezuela abre empresas públicas a la
inversión privada en un giro económico
total el gobierno el presidente nicolás
maduro a vender a partir de hoy lunes 16
de mayo entre 5 y 10 por ciento de las
acciones de las principales compañías de
telecomunicaciones
hablamos de cantv movilnet y también
otras empresas para ello por supuesto me
acompaña en el estudio daniel hablando
nuestra periodista de economía de
nuestro programa directo americana y la
bienvenida feliz lunes y pues este tema
lo vamos también analizar con un
invitado no da ni claro que si raúl muy
buenos días pues recordemos que este
anuncio es viene desde la semana pasada
por parte del presidente nicolás maduro
y consistió en que un número no
identificado de empresas estatales como
ustedes lo decía va a ser democratizado
en las proporciones del 5% o el 10% de
esto en la bolsa de valores de caracas
el mandatario raúl solamente habló de la
compañía anónima nacional de teléfonos
de venezuela cantv como usted lo decía
también de movilnet que es de telefonía
móvil pero si dio luces sobre los
sectores que estarían involucrados
además de telecomunicaciones están en
petroquímica petróleo gas natural
minería forestal aluminio y servicios la
única empresa que se dijo no va a estar
dentro de esta lista es de pedevesa la
empresa de petróleos de venezuela así es
danny como ya se lo venía anunciando
también a nuestra audiencia vamos a
presentar entonces a nuestro invitado
para analizar lo que significa esto para
la economía venezolana noel es carlo
fernández gallardo presidente de
fedecámarás y empresario carlos muy buen
día gracias por estar con nosotros en
directo américa de france 24 quiero
empezar preguntándole qué significa esto
para la economía venezolana cuáles van a
ser sus implicaciones directas
pero muchas gracias por la invitación
por la oportunidad nosotros las
consideramos que es una decisión en la
dirección y dirección correcta y
obviamente necesita muchísimo más de
profundización primero creo que a un
anuncio de muy alto nivel es esencial en
los detalles que es necesario para poder
analizar el impacto profundo este de la
decisión tiene varios elementos que
llaman la atención que son importante
resaltar que en primer lugar está
hambriento de la participación privada
ganada a sectores que tradicionalmente
han sido reservados para el estado
monopolio público por los guardias
estatales el tema de abrir las
telecomunicaciones el tema de abrir para
la participación algunas empresas
petroleras del tema abrir la minería y
abrirla la petroquímica entre otros
sectores o pasos importantes en segundo
lugar que esto tiene para atraer una
mayor profundización porque todas las
empresas que se mencionaron de los
sectores mencionados solamente una
empresa está registrada en la bolsa de
valores de caracas que es la compañía
esté telefónica la además son empresas
de capital esté cerrado alguna inclusive
con una pequeña participación privada
como son los convenios operativos en las
zonas en la zona petrolera lo que
implicaría todo un proceso de enlistar
esa empresa en la bolsa de valores de
caracas con unas cosas muy positivas que
tienen porque como es sabido por mucho
por todos puestos para inscribirse una
una empresa en la bolsa de valores de
caracas un proceso este de apertura de
información todo un proceso de rediseño
del gobierno de la gobernanza
corporativa para hacer las gestiones muy
muy muy transparentes así que yo creo
que este esto tiene un impacto
importante más allá del levantamiento de
capital que pudiera estar pensando
algunos pues para reactivar esa esa
empresa yo creo que es un paso profundo
permitiendo al sector privado la parte
que la vieja aspiración de participar en
muchos sectores que tradicionalmente han
estado cerrados y las bondades que trae
puede estar una empresa inscrita en la
bolsa valor de caracas lo que por la
transparencia por el manejo profesional
y por la y por la presentación de
resultados que obliga este tipo de tipo
situación el señor fernández usted cree
que esto es un revés para el socialismo
al que estaban acostumbrados al que
están acostumbrados en venezuela desde
hace varios años cuando todas las
empresas fueron expropiadas por parte de
muchas de las empresas fueron
expropiadas por parte de hugo chávez
el modelo ha venido dando aldabonazo de
que de su agotamiento y obviamente en
los últimos años se ha visto un proceso
de acercamiento hacia las soluciones de
mercados lo que algunos han llamado la
flexibilización del socialismo del siglo
21 entendido como si les salimos real
duro etcétera y hoy en día avanzando más
a soluciones de mercado hoy en día hay
libre tránsito de monedas extranjeras se
pueden repatriar este capitales hay
libertad para la fijación de precio ha
venido habiendo un proceso y nosotros
consideramos por eso se decimos que en
la menor medida la dirección correcta
porque viene a acompañar los que han
sido las principales medidas tomado en
los últimos años pero que por supuesto
un pequeño anuncio que necesita
muchísimo más que profundizar muchísimo
más para realmente saber cuál es el
objetivo de esta pequeña apertura y cuál
es el alcance que va a tener por ahora
por ahora lo vemos con beneplácito y por
supuesto dispuesto a contribuir pudiera
que sea este exitoso y sea lo más
transparente posible y que realmente se
democratice el capital para todos
aquellos que quieren participar y no
para personas vinculadas esferas del
poder claro carlos pero también que le
garantiza a estas personas que quisieran
invertir en estas empresas que no se
repita en algún momento lo que ocurrió
en aquel entonces con el presidente de
hugo chávez que hizo todas las empresas
privadas públicas no cuál es la garantía
de todas estas personas teniendo en
cuenta que el gobierno desde hace 20
años en venezuela tiende a ser un poco
autoritario y no respetaría las
decisiones y las garantías democráticas
para invertir en ese país quien además
serían los interesados en esta situación
política y económica en venezuela en
invertir en estas empresas sería también
la misma gente de la esfera del chavismo
que invertiría en estas empresas
pero precisamente va a depender de la
profundización este que se dé que las
reglas se terminen aplicando sin duda
alguna que la garantía plena no esté no
la tendremos propio de estos de estos
mercados pero bueno si se analiza lo que
ha venido haciendo el devenir en los
últimos años y se acercamiento pues
hacia el mercado yo creo que es
preferible tener abierta al mercado este
que no tenerlas creo que la sociedad
gana más con esta apertura este que no
no teniendo la apertura y en el caso de
algunas por ejemplo como el caso de la
crecida de caracas el hecho de que hayan
adr en la bolsa de nueva york etcétera
etcétera no es que te da digamos una
garantía plena pero si pones también a
otros intereses ya otros ya otros
mecanismos en la observación del devenir
del desentendimiento es desempeño desde
empresas y que es sin duda de alto
riesgo y el apetito dependerá de la
profundización que se tenga de la
transparencia que se dé y del
acompañamiento que se haga de modo
institucional por eso es que muchas
veces por elementos que hacen
seguimientos a los temas de venezuela
esta institución como como máximo
representante del sector empleador del
país ha insistido en la necesidad de la
reinstitucionalización de las decisiones
políticas y públicas del país porque
sólo a través de una re
institucionalización y una recuperación
del estado de derecho se va a generar la
confianza para que vuelvan los
inversionistas en los montos y en los
plazos de la economía venezolana claro
el señor fernández no se han dado muchos
detalles de cuáles son exactamente las
empresas que saldrían a la bolsa
solamente se han mencionado dos y se ha
dicho que pedevesa no va a estar primero
porque pedevesa no estaría dentro de
esta lista y segundo que podemos decir
de esas empresas que probablemente
podrían estar como en su salud
financiera o que hacen
bueno yo creo que una de las
características nuestras precisamente es
la falta de la falta de información
nosotros no podríamos poner ahorita como
está en esas y esas empresas lo que sí
sabemos que son empresas que tienen
activos importantes activos en todo el
país tienen monopolios estadales que
alguna manera les han garantizado pues
cierta es de cierta estabilidad también
gente tiene algunas tan algunas están
golpeadas porque bueno tienen muchos
años que con una tarifa prácticamente
congelada de una economía inflacionaria
que no les ha permitido hacer las
inversiones necesarias para mantenerse
en las mejores prácticas y en el estado
del arte y quizás precisamente sea la
necesidad de recursos para para poder
actualizar su plataforma tecnológica y
mejorar su calidad de servicio lo que
está digamos motivando la apertura de
esta participación es este el sector
privado así que un bloque práctico como
le decía al principio una de las cosas
que más celebramos no solamente es la
entrada del capital para mejorar la
empresa sino que esa entrada de capital
necesariamente implica todas serie de
reformas para hacer más transparente
para tener más información para tener
una mejor gobernanza y por supuesto si
quieres tener y es mantener el atractivo
sobre tus inversionistas tendrás que
tener una gestión que sea rentable que
rinda los dividendos necesarios para que
se mantenga el interés el universo yo
creo que es un cambio profundo y con
respecto de veces siempre será quizás la
última yo creo que esto este es también
un es un globo de ensayo para ver la
reacción política no todos en el partido
de gobierno están tan abiertos a la
apertura de la flexibilidad como puede
estar el presidente de maduro y su más
cercanos colaboradores así que yo creo
que este es un primer globo de ensayo y
probablemente más adelante entendemos
que incluye algunas empresas mixtas que
estaban en la en los convenios
operativos con petróleo a venezuela y a
lo mejor probablemente mañana veamos una
apertura a la participación privada en
la explotación petrolera lo que sí yo
creo que nunca estaremos viendo es
porque es un tema ya digamos consolidado
en la creencia venezolano es la isla
digamos la propiedad soberana sobre el
recurso natural pero lo que sí está bien
la sociedad venezolana es la discusión
sobre quién explota y quién comercializa
dígame quién lleva adelante el negocio
así que nosotros por eso insistimos es
un paso en la dirección correcta carlos
también usted hablaba anteriormente esta
institucionalidad de algunas
organizaciones y algunas empresas como
para que de alguna manera haya
transparencia y regularizar después toda
la economía de venezuela ya bastante
golpeada
en esos en estos últimos años sin sin
olvidar por supuesto que ha tenido pues
este real también digamos debido a la
dolarización no oficial en venezuela esa
institucionalización de las empresas
sería posible la ve usted viable que
también el gobierno tenga transparencia
para que la economía de venezuela pues
vuelva a funcionar como una economía de
mercado normalizada
bueno yo creo
a cabo
aunque tenemos que tenemos que trabajar
y yo creo que el el hecho de la apertura
y sobre todo se permite la participación
de capitales extranjeros institucionales
etcétera comienza a generar
correspondencia
antes abrir a la participación ciudadana
en los espacios tradicionalmente
reservados al estado yo creo que va a ir
en ese sentido pero necesita un
acompañamiento de la institucionalidad
pública esos esfuerzos de diálogo que se
venían de salir llevando a cabo en
méxico y que pensamos que pronto se
vuelve a retomar entre los principales
partidos de oposición y el gobierno con
el acompañamiento de países externos y
el involucramiento de los eeuu en el
manejo de las sanciones como elemento de
negociación yo creo que son importantes
para darle profundidad a la
institucionalización del país que
permitan reglas claras que permita
independencia este de poderes que retrae
y devuelva el imperio de la ley del
estado de derecho que son elementos
necesarios para que realmente todos
aquellos
y que se quieran hacer los temas de
inversiones tengan realmente un impacto
positivo y profundo si carlos
rápidamente esto podría ser una puerta
abierta para que los inversionistas
lleguen otra vez a venezuela y qué
disposición tendrían los inversionistas
internacionales en llegar a venezuela el
año pasado se entregaron unas empresas
para administración del sector privado
en el sector de alimentos cómo les fue
pero yo creo que las dos preguntas en
los mercados nacionales vientos interés
sobre venezuela porque muchos consideran
que pueden haber diste este rendimiento
muy retorno muy importante si te tome en
cuenta por es un ejemplo cualquier
inmueble en caracas su costo es mucho
más barato que su costo de construcción
su precio 20 es menor que su costo de
construcción y así una serie de activos
se encuentran en el país digamos amor
amor a muy buenos con eso y los
impresionistas vendrán este solo en
tanto y en cuanto sientan que de alguna
manera vaya es posible que garantías no
solamente para su propiedad sino para
sacar digamos éste los retornos que
obtenga y que se permitan estar estable
más o menos estable con respecto a los
momentos el momento en que entraron así
que yo yo creo que quien tras esto estas
clases que se entrega a cara no han sido
cosas importantes han sido cosas
pequeñas básicamente lo que se ha
entregado es la operación y no la nuda
propiedad éste esté sobre los activos
sólo es una cosa que hemos cuestionado
que ha sido muy transparente nos informa
la opinión pública no son procesos de
licitación sino básicamente acuerdos
digamos
se gana los círculos del poder sin la
participación del empresariado
que requiere
por ley